depuis que je suis tout petit le rêve de
ma vie c'est de participer aux jeux
olympiques et vie tu n'es pas un athlète
il faut juste que je trouve le bon sport
je vais être sauteur à skis vertueux si
c'est moi qui vais le tuer
le saut à skis ça commence à 5 ou 6 ans
il paraît que vous êtes un champion
alors vous pourriez peut-être me donner
des conseils
laisse tomber tu là je te l'a beaucoup
il me poussait symbo tu veux que je te
pousse
qu'est ce que c'est au jeu pc pas que
ces cas n'a pas du tout l'intention
d'abandonner réaliser je sais ce que
c'est d'être mis au rancart tu l'auras
tournure de boire mais tu vas en battez
vous faites honte à ce sport ghosn
n'ai-je pas le droit de représenter mon
pays le
le comité olympique britannique et c'est
de me décourager il faut que je
réussisse la presse veut connaître votre
histoire
je me suis toujours fait virer des
équipes où j'ai fait avant même d'avoir
pu faire mes preuves
je prends le saut à skis très au sérieux
et j'adore clouer le bec mes détracteurs
courageux que tout
les concurrents
tu est évident
7 heures
certes il est possible